[Music]
why are you here
Ral I lost my
job the baby's going to be here pretty
soon no
respect what do you do with those
feelings you know you could be a part of
our
family I know some guys they like to
help out guys like us what they're like
buddies ears
the doctor wants me to get a bunch of
tests tests are so expensive do you
still want to go through with
it other guys like they live with you
just like regular families except
regular folks don't get to choose their
family we do how would that work depends
on
you why do we make ourselves so much
smaller than we
are
pain that holds us back take back your
power
Ralph welcome Ralph son manad
Drome what if I'm just
broken you have to raise an army inside
yourself baby you really got to tell me
what's going on
here watch out for yourself
okay
it
starts there is no God but
Ralph
what you decide will be the only thing
there
is I'm about to tell
[Music]
the